-Guys, today is Thursday.
But I feel like
I was very busy today,
and I need some time to write
out my thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that okay?
I'd like to write out
some right now.
James, do you have any
thank-you-note-writing music
for me there, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
There he is. Classic.
There he is.
He says -- He speaks with
his eyes, you know?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, Colorado Avalanche,
for winning the Stanley Cup
in, well, a landslide.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you,
setting off firecrackers,
for letting my uncle's fingers
celebrate
their independence
from his hand.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
"Was it worth it?"
"Nah. No, it wasn't."
Thank you, inflatable pool toys,
for sometimes not springing
a leak for a whole six minutes.
Oh, that's interesting.
[ Applause ]
Repair kit.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, fruit salad, for
being sangria that got sober.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not too shabby.
That's a good one.
That's not bad.
Thank you, NASA, for stopping
the sale of cockroaches
and moon dust
in illegal auctions.
I guess now if you want to buy
cockroaches and dust,
you'll have to do it
the old-fashioned way --
by renting my first apartment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It wasn't that bad.
Thank you, pistachios, for being
Pac-Mans that eat healthy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, lifeguard chairs,
for being tennis umpire chairs
on vacation.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.